on va parler justement pour cette
troisième partie des conséquences de du
hashtag le fameux hashtag lui tout seul
et ce mouvement
il a permis de libérer la parole des
femmes mais il aurait aujourd'hui des
effets indésirables sur les relations au
travail
en effet de plus en plus d'hommes
n'oserait plus travailler c'est pauvre
petit bichon avec la gente féminine
c'est bourdin direct qui nous anime le
risque est ce là un an et demi après la
vague de scandales mythe ou six manades
leron masculin sur dix se disent donc
mal à l'aise demain de la mixer dans la
collaboration l'interaction avec des
femmes la moitié de ces sommes ont peur
que les conséquences du harcèlement soit
plus désastreuses pour leur carrière
plutôt pour celle de la victime
il hésite à organiser des entretiens
individuels avec une femme a voyagé à
faire des déjeuners ou des dîners de la
travail rendre l'ascenseur une majorité
préfère travailler avec un collègue
masculin junior plutôt qu'avec une femme
expérimentée
alors on a traumatisé ces messieurs 60 %
des supérieurs masculins ce deal se
disent mal à l'aise dans la
collaboration la socialisation
l'interaction avec des collègues
féminines est alors un chiffre
absolument incroyable 50% des hommes
affirment que les conséquences des
plaintes de harcèlement sexuel sont plus
dommageables pour la carrière de lars
eller que pour celle des victimes
quand même dix mois mais voilà donc je
voudrais avoir d'abord honneur à ces
dames caroline qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette évolution des relations ces
messieurs disent ne plus oser travailler
moi j'ai entendu des gens notamment ici
ben oui mais moi je ne ferme plus la
porte du bureau si je suis seul avec une
femme
on ne sait jamais ce qu'elle peut dire
après etc mais qu'est ce qu'on en pense
fait la meilleure de l'année
c'est la meilleure c'est vraiment des
petits salopards vous envoie ce qu'on
vous aime bien par ailleurs mais
sincèrement ils se servent en fait de
cet argument qui est un truc qui pour
nous est très progressiste pour en faire
un truc à linverse c'est quand même la
perversion poussé à l'extrême est de
toute façon ils trouveraient quoi que ce
soit et trouverez toujours une une
excuse pour nous exclure et nous faire
croire que tu mon n'est finalement pas
si on est finalement nous le problème de
leur existence
donc c'est quand même soif en manque de
corones espagnol donc
ça pue si vous avez donc donc ça manque
un peu de courage ça manque beaucoup et
c'est vraiment le système est pervers
parce que c'est vraiment utilisé est-ce
que vous comprenez tout de même la
détresse de certains qui disent je ne
sais plus comment m'adresser pas du ca
une femme dans le cadre du travail
pressé jouanno d'un homme
adressez vous à nous comme vous aiderez
seriez à qui que ce soit venir est aussi
un très bon vous voyez leur côté rageuse
la g
je ne regarde plus tes photos je vais
pas pour moi ici je sens que ça vous
énerve ça vous irrite on ne fait plus
attention vous mais c'est parce qu'à
part un petit peu d'hypocrisie de la
part de ces messieurs qui dit je ne sais
plus comment m'adressais à une femme
pardon mais le simple bon sens nous
explique qu'on sait comment à peu près
s'adresser à une femme
il n'y a absolument aucun souci quand on
est à peu près au corps ticket
normalement et qu'on est capable
s'adresser normalement ce qu'ils
racontent ça maintenant on peut
plaisanter mais ce qu'ils racontent ça
c'est des mecs qui en ont pas
effectivement quoi moi ça m'a jamais
fait peur d'aller discuter même avec 1,6
g non mais ceci dit à avoir poussé le
bouchon trop loin ça a créé ce genre de
poussin mais non mais parce que
maintenant tu regardes une fille dans la
rue la d1 fois j'ai regardé une fille à
la radio et je vais dire assez marrant
ton pantalon il fait des belles fesses
il ya trois personnes
mais la fille a super bien répondu et
elle a répondu ah bah moi je préfère
qu'il me dise ça plutôt que ne me disent
rien du tout baisse et est passé à
l'achat et super-g répondu c'est jusqu'à
l'aide aussi les que c'était sa façon de
répondre qu'on peut plus entrepris mais
se dire des petites choses l'ordre 2 ou
2 lors de la cdu critiques de louis
battu droit tu portes très bientôt jean
cas pas me parler de mes fesses
on n'a pas me parler de mission n'a pas
parlé de ça et c'est toi comment
voulions donner aux banques la barre
l'asthme en parler mais j'ai pas besoin
de toi pour en parler maintenant le
problème de ces garçons comme d'habitude
cdc des faux jetons comme d'habitude ce
sont des lâches
nous versons cherche toujours doit se
cacher de parler convenablement ça fait
que je me sente harcelés ou que je
ressente une violence le problème des
personnes vous souhaitant duo on entend
que ça c'est du monde l'amour quand les
eaux vont être capables au palais
farnèse à ses velléités de sortie digne
et qu'on ne sait pas comment ils peuvent
réagir et que même une parole anonyme
pourrait conduire à tout c'est parce
qu'ils ont tous des cadavres dans leurs
placards et aujourd'hui problème donc
déjà pour te calmes et ludivine mais si
tu te fais rien de faire un compliment
qui est calme tenté comme ça moi je
tiens à complimenter de très beaux
cheveux j'ai un peu fou mais très beau
mais très bien ça tu te calmes non mais
parce que là tu as dit tous es tu à
généraliser ce truc n'a été fait le
plein
tu as dit tous les patrons tous les mecs
cadiou comme pressenti va prendre leur
défense mais les jeux ne prend pas leur
défense anglaise est immédiat mais alors
pas tomber je te dis juste qu'il ya
trois-quatre abrutis qui font parler
d'eux ok moins que voilà faut les
laisser de côté mais c'est absolument
pas tous les patrons on n'a pas tous
peur de s'adresser aux femmes
vous vous êtes des cas particuliers on a
peur peur de s'adresser à vous parce que
voilà on vous venez d humour et tout
s'est un peu compliqué mais sinon les
autres on n'a pas de problème avec m
vous savez e thibault vous savez par
exemple est ce qu on entend beaucoup
d'hommes dire après ce mouvement me to
qui a libéré la parole etc
on ne sait plus comment s'adresser aux
femmes est ce que vous vous dites je
sais parfaitement comment m'adresser aux
femmes je n'ai pas d'angoissé
particulière
je suis dans mon rôle je sais exactement
quel est mon rôle et comment je dois m
vaincus 1 goisses mais chaque cas est
particulier en effet on fait de l'humain
donc il ya des la psychologie ce matin
en effet pendant la matinale est une
femme de la matinale qui m'a mis une
main aux fesses quoi je ne me suis pas
sentie harceler parce que j'apprécie ça
à la télé chaque panneau
saft chaque cas est particulier en effet
et donc je me sens jamais abandonné ma
maison dans cette chaîne info que ses
news on met des mains aux fesses au
sectionnement et ça fait plaisir
on pourrait amener des médecins
maintenant quand on fait un examen
médical par exemple à ce que vous fermez
la porte de votre cabinet vous recevez
une femme qui va se mettre à bloc par
exemple quand ils font des examens
gynécologiques maintenant qu'ils
laissent la porte légèrement entrouvert
pour pas être sujet à une une attaque
quand on fait un examen des pressions
qu'on adapte aux risques discours j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes auto
électivement harceleuse non mais c'est
une réalité quand je m'en a parlé la
dernière fois dans ses rangs il est
arrivé du ciel tu fais un rêve et
regardons aujourd'hui normalement avant
tu t'en levé le t-shirt eu des graves et
le soutien-gorge tuf électrocardiogramme
là maintenant est ce que vous pourriez
ce que par ben alors qu'on fait un
examen médical donc ça veut dire que ça
a créé quand même une angoisse à une
réalité que vous ne veut que vous n'avez
pas fait pendant des années parce que
vous avez pensé vous pouviez tout ça
surtout que ça on ne le nie pas non plus
on sait que ces choses sont arrivées il
ya des femmes harcelées
maintenant il ya aussi il inverse qui
existe les footballeurs je connais ce
domaine et des footballeurs il ya des
femmes qui viennent juste pour leur
argent qui font des enfants et qui s'en
vont ou non mais ça arrive dans tous les
coups pour ça que c'est comme si c'était
une généralité
donc vous vous êtes compris jusque là
oui voilà pourtant quand même il ya
aujourd'hui des hommes qui préfèrent
travailler avec un stagiaire qu'avec une
femme mais j'ai sont les jeunes sur le
monsieur des petits bras on a posé la
question à nos téléspectateurs le
hashtag mis tous at-il selon vous
changer les rapports entre les hommes et
les femmes
oui ou non ben oui comme qu'il emporte
tout de même à d'une courte tête à 51%
mais non pour 49% s'agit pas comme ici
de 2 2 contre 2 de salins dites nous ce
que vous en pensez et comptines et là il
a legal urbain sur l'âge taxi chute des
des témoignages à nous faire parvenir
peut-être que vous avez vous aussi eu ce
sentiment pas parfois de pas être prises
en compte au contraire de plus savoir
comment vous adresser à ces dames